coffee on a Tuesday and block six
I was trying to figure out what I should
do for my next vlog so I went upstairs
and talk to my neighbor Xia he told me
he's been dying to go to the big
Scientology complex in Sunset Boulevard
so I said perfect where we going
beautiful world's filled with the John
Travolta Tom Cruise known as Scientology
here it is Church of Scientology
Kershner parking on
they didn't let us take the camera
inside so I'll just tell you what
happened next we were greeted by a
receptionist who look like he was 19
years old and looked us straighten yeah
everybody in that building looks you
straight in the eye the first thing he
did was pushed forward a piece of paper
on which we were supposed to write our
first name our last name our address our
phone number and the reason why we were
coming here we said that we were
interested in the religion and that we
wanted to know more about it so he
suggested that we take the self-guided
multimedia tour this is an invitation to
freedom man can save his son so in the
back part of the lobby there's all these
interactive TVs where you can watch
different aspects of Scientology and
move your way around and learn all the
different types of things I got these
two sample DVDs first the way to
happiness and second Scientology and
overview there was a booth on
Scientology ethics there was a booth on
the evil of psychiatry I've never agreed
with psychiatry ever before I was a
Scientologist I never agreed with
psychiatry and then when I started
studying the history of psychiatry I
started realizing more and more why I
didn't agree with psychiatry there's a
booth that start to explain the
philosophy of Scientology there was a
booth all about l ron Hubbard there was
even a booth where you can see your own
thoughts this is the device that you use
to do that looks like an old toy
telephone after the self-guided
multimedia tour we went up front and ask
to take personality tests so I think me
and C I thought that would be like a 10
to 20 question test 200 questions some
of the questions were do you feel ill at
ease in the company of children do you
whistle while you work if a ten-year-old
was acting out of place you would
approve corporal punishment you find
yourself dwelling on past misfortunes
you rarely think about past failure
you're the type of person who's always
thinking about what you could have done
does it sometimes feel that all of
reality is a dream finally a question
192 they asked the question that they
had been asking over and over in so many
different ways are you depressed it's
very very very easy to see how if you're
emotionally distressed 8 think at all I
just capture you oh yeah big ol
net on you or someone who's depressed or
who just feels particularly empty for
someone who's tried psychology and
psychiatry and it hasn't worked for them
why not adopt the idea that psychiatry
is actually evil sometimes it's easy for
us when we're in a vulnerable position
to take the exact opposite stance of the
stance that you had before when really
the answer is not to flip your ideas 180
degrees but only to adjust it a little
bit in either way but anyway in five
minutes the receptionist returned with
the result of our personality tests here
it is you can see that it's a line graph
showing where it is you are in between
the spectrum of several different traits
the young Scientologist said to me now
sir this is not our opinion of you this
is a scientific analysis of your opinion
of yourself so we went over the results
and he asked me a lot of questions which
I tried to answer as honestly as I could
and a big deal was made all the while
about how practical Scientology is see
the first step that you take after you
take the personality test is a series of
communication courses in those courses
you're met to unlearn the ways that we
learn to imperfectly communicate with
each other and I talked to a few
Scientologists there who all said that
after those courses they really learn to
open up themselves to communication and
I believe that it works for them
although it may be the clue to why they
all seem a little bit brainwashed
they're all learning communication in a
way that
makes them act the way they do you know
I assume the communications courses and
other courses the jet to take are very
specific anyway the next step is
purification so I asked him what
purification was thinking that would be
just a bunch of people sitting in a room
trying to think away the toxins he said
actually we have a few large saunas in
the facility and you sit in them and
sweat out all the toxins and the next
thing after that is the beginning of the
bridge to total freedom so here's where
I had the question that I really wanted
to ask and that was where does the
practical almost utilitarian side of
Scientology come into contact with the
religious side he couldn't answer that
question so I had to be taken to a new
Scientologist so we walked over to
another desk and I sat down and I asked
the same question but a little bit Frank
what do you worship here because
Christianity for example has got the
Bible and Jesus and this is the
infallible words of their religion now
the second Scientologist took the tact
that there is no worship going on in
Scientology now I don't know if I really
believe him on that but taking him at
his word I said then why do you call
yourselves a religion and he said well
you know the word religion has been
usurped over the years and I said yeah
maybe that's true but the religious
people have had a bird good 2,000 years
oh let's let's just give it to them I
said to him I think you're alienating
people by calling it a religion if all
it really is is a self-help community
unfortunately that's when I had to leave
because the building was closing and my
neighbors II had to get back to our
house so what did you think
it was interesting I didn't know about
their volunteer efforts but she made a
big push about sure but it was religion
you know they don't differ that much
they asked you to be good to other
people but I'm sure behind closed doors
it's like basically segregate people and
always put up walls I don't know what I
really believe about Scientology I don't
know what I think goes on in there I
don't know where the money comes from I
don't know any of these things to us on
the outside looking in Scientology is
like a frog we don't see past the doors
but I recommend anybody who's interested
to just go there because they will give
you certain answers to certain questions
and you can learn at least a little bit
about the mystery that is Scientology
make your decisions on it for yourself
but just remember give a fake name